Okay.
I've got some great books to recommend to
you today.
Um, as always, David pakman.com/recommendations
for all of my recommendations.
If you use the links there to buy these books
on Amazon, we get a slice of every transaction.
David pakman.com/recommendations today I have
two fiction, one nonfiction.
Let me start with the latest book by John
Le Carre.
As many of you know, John Le Carre, one of
my favorite authors, I think I've read all
but one of his books, um, 20 or so.
John Le Carre is extremely prolific.
He has been putting out a good book basically
every few years since the early sixties.
I think it was the early or mid sixties when
a spy who came in from the cold came out.
That might have been like 68 that was his
third book.
So I think his first one must have been 62
63 somewhere in there.
Extremely prolific.
The author of such books as the constant Gardner
spy who came in from the cold.
The tinker tailor trilogy a most wanted man
is a very good one.
Uh, the tailor of Panama.
Anyway, the last few books by John Le Carre
have been by normal standards.
Very good but not his best work.
The latest one called agent running in the
field, which published just a month or two
ago I would argue is his best book of the
last, I think I would say 10 years or even
longer.
Excellent, excellent book.
It's sort of the merging of two, uh, two different
stories.
One of a, I'm sort of retiring soon to retire
spy who, uh, is brought back home to have
sort of a relatively mundane, not particularly,
um, a well-respected position and the overlap
between that and a friend that this individual
makes when back in London that I'll tell you
that and nothing else.
Excellent book.
Very quick read.
I highly recommend it.
Number two, the latest book by Blake crouch.
Blake crouch has been a guest on this program.
Blake crouch wrote dark matter.
He authored good behavior, which has been
turned into a TV show somewhere, I think.
Although I have not seen it.
He authored wayward Pines.
I believe that's a trilogy.
I think that's been turned into a series.
His latest book is recursion.
It is a scifi book.
It is not.
It is sort of a time travel book, but not
in the traditional sense.
It's a time travel book, the likes of which
I've never read before and I'll just give
you this little grain.
If this seems interesting, then definitely
pick this one up in most time travel stories.
If I travel back to my year to do the year
I was five years old, 1989 I would be my current
age, but I would be living in 1989 and I continue
aging consecutively in this book.
The concept is I travel back to 1989 with
all of the knowledge and experience that I
currently have, but I go back to being five
years old and I'm basically reliving years
of my life.
That's the concept.
Very different than most time travel books.
Recursion by Blake crouch get this one.
If you're into a Saifai very, very good.
Sent Blake a note about it and maybe we'll
have him back on the program.
Really great stuff.
Okay.
Those are two fiction recommendations and
I have just one nonfiction recommendation
for you.
This is a thick one.
So I've been, uh, getting through fewer books
because I've been reading some, some big boys.
This is principles by Ray Daleo.
Ray Daleo is I believe in his early seventies,
seventies.
Now he is one of the most successful investors,
a lot of people know about Warren buffet.
Fewer people in sort of popular culture know
about Ray Daleo.
Maybe it's Valeo, not sure where he pronounces
it.
Uh, but this book is, it's not an investment
book, it's not a business book.
It's not an autobiography.
It's sort of all of these things and more,
and it is very interesting from the point
of view of growing an organization if you're
interested in that.
It's interesting from the point of view of
how one matures and uh, changes their perspective
on their work as they grow and age, which
I found super interesting.
And uh, it is not super dense.
I mean it's for the number of pages that it
is, which I think is like nearly 600.
Um, yes, nearly 600 pages.
It's a relatively quick read and if you're
into this type of book or even if you're not,
I would recommend that you try it.
Check out David pakman.com/recommendations
for all of these and more.
Remember, if you get any of these using the
links at David pakman.com/recommendations
we get a little slice of your transaction.
Uh, and that is of course very much appreciated.